mir geht es heute um das anders ich sagt
die ampel muss weg ich bin also seit 27
jahren fdp-mitglied und vor den wahlen
war es ja so dass er gesagt hat also ihm
fehlt eigentlich die fantasie für die
ampel und er wollte jamaika hat ja
gesagt was ist denn passiert seitdem
erstens die themen sind der andere
geworden wir haben jetzt ukraine krieg
und das hätten wir viel mehr
gemeinsamkeiten zwischen cdu fdp und
grünen und sehr wenig gemeinsamkeiten
zur spd also wenn ich mir anschaue
beispiel von dem
spd fraktionsvorsitzenden
dessen stellungnahmen zum ukraine krieg
und vergleiche das mit eimern hofreiter
von den grünen oder mit einer frau
strack zimmermann aus meiner partei das
passt einfach absolut nicht zusammen
deswegen sage ich die gemeinsamkeiten
sind größer geworden damals hat man sich
gemacht mit der cdu warum die cdu hatte
ja gar keine führung damals die waren
völlig chaostruppe inzwischen haben die
wiedereinführung die haben dann märz und
deswegen sage ich also ich wäre dafür
machen wir jetzt das was damals nicht
geklappt hat jamaika war die haben große
herausforderungen auch gerade in bezug
auf die bundeswehr auf die außen auf die
sicherheitspolitik und da passt auf
jeden fall fdp und cdu und grüne besser
zusammen als die ampel also jetzt muss
ich mache ich ja sehr gerne in dem fall
verteidigen das es eine ampel gibt und
ich sage mal ich kann ganz ganz viel
kritisieren auch an den
koalitionsvertrag in die vorgelegt haben
aber eins muss man ganz ganz sachlich
sagen
gesellschaftspolitisch gibt es viele
fortschritte ob das bei frauenrechten
dass wir hatten eben im übrigen thema
auch was menschen rechtliche fragen
betrifft da muss man sagen es ist ein
fortschritt zudem zu all den jahren wo
die union regiert hat zweitens ist das
eine spannende these aber eine die
völlig unrealistisch ist also da ich im
deutschen bundestag sitzen und dann auch
sehr wie die miteinander umgehen im
moment geht die union am herd ist mit
der fdp um ihren teilweise härter als
mit uns also da ist da ist also eine
illusion zu glauben dass das
zusammengehen und ich glaube im übrigen
dass auch inhaltliches mag einzelne
punkte geben dass da etwas zusammen geht
wissen die christian linder hat zwei
monate vor der wahl gesagt die
kanzlerfrage ist entschieden es geht
darum für vizekanzler wird herr harbecke
oder ich deswegen kann man diese dinge
glaube ich nicht ganz so ernst nehmen in
der politik ich sage ganz klar diese
ampel wird entweder zerbrechen und
neuwahlen daran glaube ich nicht sondern
die werden die legislatur tapfer zu ende
machen und ich bin gespannt ob sie die
positiven dinge des koalitionsvertrags
umsetzen und bei den negativen wir
werden bescheiden die linke kleine
opposition seien aber deutlich als
erwartet wenn sie jetzt sagen dass es
unrealistisch gebe dazu also man darf
hier einfach mal was wünschen
hätte ich mir wird den links aber
ehrlich gesagt die zeit das wünschen
noch geholfen hat ist ja leider vorbei
wünschen würde ich mir 51 prozent fdp ja
aber ich mach ich jetzt koste haben
150 plätzen das jetzt vielleicht noch
ein bisschen realistischer als der
wunsch sind aber im übrigen wenn er sich
gehen gerne in dem christian lindner als
karla aber wenn sie natürlich jetzt die
ampel habe sagt gesellschaft werden wie
das fortschritte gezeigt wird dann ist
es ja fast stärkste argument was man
gegen die ampel vorbringen da wissen sie
haben sich das wenn sie das los dazu
also nochmal das unrealistische da gibt
es auch noch viele andere gründe
gesellschaftspolitisch habe ich das
gesagt nehmen sie die abschaffung des
119 a das ist ein fortschritt was denn
sonst nehmen sie die
einwanderungspolitik das was dort an
gedacht es ist ein fortschritt man hat
da immer noch viel zu kritisieren aber
das sind dinge die nach vorne geht ich
sage auch ganz klar ein mindestlohn von
zwölf euro sind fortschritt das war
jetzt nicht unbedingt das kernthema der
fdp also es gibt dinge wo ich sage ja
wohl das ist vernünftig ich habe ganz im
übrigen auch das thema
kindergrundsicherung da habe ich nur
inzwischen große sorge dass es auch
passieren wird das ist eine
kindergrundsicherung gelb gibt aber
insgesamt ich wie soll ich verteidige
jetzt ich kenne die sendung reicht nicht
aus wenn dich das kritische alles
aufrufen das ist klar aber im vergleich
zu der großen koalition und dem
stillstand und die union ist wirklich in
einer lage die haben sich so daran
gewöhnt das ist nur gut dass jede
opposition sind besser wäre natürlich
reine doch einmal herrn händler wie denn
jetzt die nrw wahl steht vor der tür
doktor doktor
150 sich zu amerika wird es denn nrw
klappen aktuell bei den hochrechnungen
wahrscheinlich nicht also in die
bundesländer haben wir ganz verschiedene
farben der die fdp beispielsweise ist in
sachsen anhalt in einer deutschland
koalition mit sozialdemokraten und
christdemokraten wir haben eine ampel in
rheinland-pfalz jamaika in
schleswig-holstein und eine
schwarz-gelbe vielleicht klassische
koalition in düsseldorf in nrw und das
ist auch gut so und im boot auf der
bundesebene haben eine ampel koalition
jetzt muss ich ein doktortitel mann der
sicher auch gerade als fdp-mitglied
geoutet hat und das heißt dass auch fdp
untereinander diskutieren können
widersprechen mir fehlte damals im
sommer so hat es christian lindner
formuliert auch ein wenig die fantasie
die ist nicht nur entstanden sondern
jetzt auch vertrauen gewachsen weil ich
habe das mit bekommen diese gespräche
die grüne und freie demokraten mit der
union versucht haben das war zum
scheitern verurteilt deswegen war es zu
dem zeitpunkt da sind wir uns
hoffentlich einig keine option in eine
jamaika koalition zu gehen denn der
zustand der union hieß führungslose ich
hatte dabei erinnerte und jetzt in einer
situation wo wir auch ein bischen
rückblicken müssen uns anschauen was ist
das erbe von 16 jahre cdu/csu und bund
als regierung und da sage ich das ist
nicht so dolle bei der bundeswehr haben
wir ein erbe angetreten wo wir es jetzt
gerade ausbügeln müssen in der
energiepolitik herr dr dr -titel man das
korrekt gesagt dass auch hat auch gerade
gesagt in der energiepolitik sein erbe
angetreten mit krasser abhängigkeit von
russland die jetzt ein aggressor
geworden sind das heißt da sind ja
heftige fehler gemacht worden und ich
finde da kann es frische neuer koalition
das verbessern und dann komme ich
letzter satz zu den ampel projekten die
großen gegenüber 1 werden wir gleich
noch sprechen das habe ich mich heute
als thema dabei aber das thema
beispielsweise eine echte planungs
beschleunigung digitalisierung
entbürokratisierung gott wie lange
warten wir darauf unternehmer die lust
haben durchzustarten start ups die
brauchen das das zweite thema ist das
thema bildung vernachlässigt auf der
bundesebene von der union ich habe mich
immer geärgert ich habe dietmar bartsch
auch da hat der bund 5 milliarden für
den digital praktische schulen da sind
wenige prozent 34 prozent von
abgeflossen weil die union ist nicht
gebacken kriegt hat die ja die
bundesbildungsministerin zu dem
zeitpunkt stellte dass das geld bei den
schulen ankommt jetzt während der
regierungszeit der ampel und die fdp
stellt die bundesbildungsministerin ist
schon viel mehr vor ort angekommen also
dann war ganz viel
modernisierungsprojekte ich hatte nur
macht einen guten job gemacht
fantastischen job und das sind nicht nur
gesellschaftspolitische projekt das sind
auch wirtschaft politische projekte und
die war mit der union nicht zu machen
und so erneuert herr doktor doktor titel
mann ist die union noch nicht wie sie
sein müsste für regional wirklich würds
mir auch noch sehr viel mehr eine
erneuert wünschen aber jetzt ist
natürlich auch bis unfair märz
verantwortlich zu machen für die
schlechte bilanz von der frau merkel
also dass die frau merkel eine
katastrophale bilanz sagt da bin ich mir
sofort einig mit ihnen aber jetzt zu
sagen das ist die schuld vor dem herrn
merz also das ist dann doch ein bisschen
unfair aber ich habe ja von der außen
und sicherheitspolitik gesprochen und
die glaube ich die wird immer wichtiger
egal wie lang der ukraine krieg noch
dauert ja wir haben ein riesenprogramm
vor uns die bundeswehr zu stärken und da
glaube ich da gibt es sehr viel mehr
gemeinsamkeiten zum beispiel zwischen
ihrer partei aber auch zwischen der der
spd auch zwischen der afg hat das sind
ja drei parteien die jetzt eigentlich in
bezug auf ukraine und russland ähnliche
position vertreten und da gibt es aber
umgekehrt sehr viel mehr gemeinsamkeiten
zwischen der cdu und zwischen der fdp
und auch zwischen großen teilen der
grünen und dass diese fragestellung
bundeswehr aus und sicherheitspolitik
die haben doch bei den
koalitionsverhandlungen die ganze
untergeordnete rolle gespielt und
wahlkampf praktisch gar keine rolle
gespielt aber heute sind die top themen
das heißt wir haben veränderte
fragestellungen und veränderte
fragestellung wiederum die müssen auch
dazu führen dass man sich veränderte
gedanken gemacht über koalition darf
sich eine steile gegenthese aus der
arterie deutschland sagen die rot-grüne
koalition unter gerhard schröder den wir
alle nicht mehr sehen wollen in der
deutschen politik heute als person aber
damals die großen sozialstaats reform
diabate kritisiert wir haben einen
wirtschaftlichen aufschwung für
deutschland gebracht habe ist eine
rot-grüne hat mir nie erwartet jetzt
eine ampelkoalition die bereit ist 100
milliarden euro in die bundeswehr zu
investieren also vordergründig herr dr
zillmann mögen sie herr doktor doktor
titel man mögen sie erstmal vermeintlich
recht habe man wirklich anguckt was
können regierungen leisten dann merken
wir historisch in deutschland dass
gerade die etwas ungewöhnlicheren
koalitionen die größeren reform
hinbekommen haben deswegen glaube ich
dass dieser ampel er die kraft hat weil
man es ihr nicht so zutraut nicht so
nach sagt vielleicht dass sie erschafft
die bundeswehr wirklich zu stärken als
es mit der union möglich gewesen wäre
einsatz die 100 milliarden für die
bundeswehr hättest bei jamaika glaube
ich nicht gegeben was dürfen wir uns
denn dann davon versprechen davon daraus
dürfen wir uns versprechen dass wir ein
beweis einfach mal in den ersten 100
tagen haben wir schon und dann waren wir
mit diesem furchtbaren krieg
konfrontiert haben wir schon geschafft
dass wir energie unabhängiger von
russland geworden sind beim erdgas beim
erdöl bei der kohle haben wir jetzt die
möglichkeit sogar ganz uns von russland
abzukoppeln also in den wenigen tagen in
den wenigen monaten seit dem haben wir
das schon geschafft und insofern ist das
was wir jetzt machen müssen und die
anderen projekte und einzig mir ganz
persönlich am herzen die stehen im
koalitionsvertrag wir müssen das
aufstiegsversprechen der sozialen
marktwirtschaft erneuern in deutschland
wer run klotz der lust hat zu arbeiten
wäre eine tolle ausbildung hat weil er
richtig geackert hat als junger mensch
der muss davon auch was haben der muss
sich etwas aufbauen können dieses
aufstiegsversprechen ist unter der union
verloren gegangen und das wird die ampel
jetzt nach vorne bringen die
entscheidende frage ist ja dass man auch
die ampel dann die taten messen sollte
ich habe nicht die aktions versprach
gesprochen und habe das was zu loben ist
auch gelobt ich nehme jetzt mal das
thema energiepolitik raus also so kann
man ja das begeistert aufnehmen das
jetzt mit katar und anderen ländern dort
gespräche laufen ich kann nur sagen ich
war dabei schon im deutschen bundestag
dass nach den furchtbaren attentaten in
new york gesagt wurde von denen müssen
wir unabhängig werden und da ist viel
raus gegangen also von einem despoten
zum nächsten das eigentliche ist doch
dass energiewende was alle sagen
erneuerbarer energien ausbaue reduktion
usw da warte ich noch die abhängigkeit
von russland zu reduzieren also jetzt
nämlich mal russland weg wir nehmen das
mal die kohle also in deutschland sind
wir so unendlich stolz dass wir aus der
steinkohle ausgestiegen sind das ist ja
auch in ordnung nur für importieren
steinkohle jetzt irgendwie aus kolumbien
wo die kohle leute sagen dann mit stadt
liegen immer noch eine leiche auf dem
schiff also das sagt nicht ich hätte ist
doch irgend etwas schräg wir machen wir
wir müssen doch wir müssen doch wenn wir
das wollen und ich weiß dass das keine
leichte aufgabe ist aber bitte dann eine
perspektive auf machen die dann wirklich
dazu führt dass das disputen frei ist
und das ist ein riesenproblem und ich
will noch ein satz sagen also wirklich
widersprechen der these dass wir in der
russland politik eine ähnliche position
haben wir auf 508 das stimmt überhaupt
also das ist eine glatte lüge